I'm done with the neighbor here at
bleacher report and I'm playing that's
my god let me do that
bring it back bring it back three star
tight end coming out of high school in
Georgia record 40 speed for a defensive
lineman and the Mississippi state line
back coach called him Danny Green Gary
Green Green
that's my guy oh you sound of Georgia
oh yeah dirtiest widow trip he played
tight in it went to Stone Mountain we
played together at Mississippi State
head on trip and I said Gary cuz you
called him Danny Green chirping all
right this person's family settled in
Georgia after the Civil War long lineage
of semi pro pro football and his family
and he was a track and field standout
and in high school capture the state
title in the
Allen oh my people shot put Georgia
Malcolm Nielsen me cohort my like Nick
like this I know they they did they did
talk nobody Nick was the quietest
personal team's okay this person oldest
brother works as a radiologist in New
York he was the backup quarterback at
Dayton and his nickname is Chuck Jon
Rudy that's my guy
sy that's my guy he's well deserving at
the nickname chickie that's him day in
and day out and in college he recorded
134 catches pudgy he went to Auburn holy
dog I went to Auburn we're talking with
Oliver I have no clue this is crazy
hi I know there I knew that yes I knew
that
you should have said out of George's I
wouldn't knew it Cam Newton Colin
pledgee yes I know he do got a good this
is crazy
final person he is once described as a
genuine southern country boy he often
beat you in rock paper scissor
and he played up Mississippi crying
Martin I go on Martin is going hey MJ I
know that I can't be you know I came to
get him
that's my guy oh my god the way he talks
oh my god MJ each piece pairs every
single word who his favorite word like
if you asked him a question and
something that he doesn't think it's
true it never failed be like GU GU that
guy right there is a character but I
wish him a speedy recovery just
explicitly yesterday I'm jonesin Avram
here at bleacher report and I just pray
that's my god